[Aplausos]
pero tengo 39 años y yo soy actor médico
eso sí 15 años y soy profesor de
improvisación que tal hace 8
para quitarse un poco de mí - puedo
decirles que yo estudié la carrera de
comunicaciones terminé muy bien
todo lo contrario con la actuación yo he
estado en muchos talleres con el niño
y nunca termina
a eso me dedico
la chapa de la actuación es un proceso
por el cual yo pude conocer un mundo
cuando era niño yo era una persona bueno
sigo siendo creo una persona muy
extrovertida tengo mucha energía y
necesitaba un lugar donde ocupar la mi
madre supo hacer eso llevándome a cursos
de dulce de natación oratoria fútbol
mini básquet teatro al final el teatro
quedó cuando uno es niño el mundo es un
lugar muy importante nosotros tenemos
muchos sueños y nuestros futuros son
dorados queremos ser tal vez gimnastas
de categoría olímpica futbolistas
astronautas todo lo podemos hacer todo
lo que nosotros queremos lo podemos
hacer
después de eso va pasando el tiempo y
nos damos cuenta de que tu disfraz las
posibilidades van recortando
tenemos tal vez 11 años yo creo que
estás un poco viejo para poder ser un
gimnasta de categoría olímpica
x 2 15 18 24 32 la línea de tu vida se
vuelve única directa e irrepetible por
las decisiones que tú has tomado tal vez
que tienes personas que dependen de ti y
cuando eso ocurre por ejemplo no sé
quién es un bebé el que no tienes para
postre che y tú tienes que hacer lo
necesario para poder
avanzado subsistir estar con él pero
cuando uno es niño
es capaz de salud
le comento esto señores porque a lo
largo de estos años lo que he ha partido
de trabajar con jóvenes es son dos
realidades
digo en realidad es una la palabra
verdad es porque yo creo en la medida de
mi entendimiento que nosotros gozamos de
verdades y de medias verdades una época
de mi vida que yo pensaba que eran
mentiras y eso era motivado por la
inmadurez de piedra tal vez
los jóvenes tienen dos realidades número
uno no sabe lo que quiere
dos se mueren de ganas por que alguien
le diga lo que tiene que hacer como si
no supiera como si no siempre lo hubiera
tenido claro o alguno ustedes también lo
tiene claro no sé quiénes son los que
están acá tal vez no son de estudiantes
de la umh y otros son muy jóvenes 18 19
20 21 años y tal vez cuando terminamos
el colegio nos llenamos un servidumbres
rellenándose tensión nos llenamos de
angustia porque no sabemos qué es lo que
va a ocurrir y ella es el punto que
nosotros nos equivocamos por qué por qué
no nos damos cuenta de la libertad que
tenemos tienes 18 19 17 años estaba en
el colegio y no sabes lo que quieres
hacer es evidente
hoy día vas a ver qué carrera vas a
elegir por restituida
me encantaría decirles a todos ustedes
que estoy en la universidad de que usted
tiene una seguridad
nosotros no tenemos una seguridad
estudiar una carrera en una universidad
es un plus es un valor agregado hoy por
hoy también es un lujo tremendo gracias
al viernes tenés un valor agregado es
algo más nosotros tenemos que entender
por qué porque me encantaría decirle que
no sé también tú estudias derecho
medicina ingeniería pasa del tema de las
pestañas son 8
ocho años siete años terminas no estoy
seguro que es paz porque por qué
esta es la realidad nuestros padres
hace 25 30 nos estaban dando que se
llama estabilidad laboral era mucho más
tranca de que te saquen el trabajo
grabaste quedamos nosotros
no tenemos entonces cómo podemos empezar
a ver más allá
como porque tenemos que empezar a
dividir las cosas de lo que nos gusta
hacer de lo que nosotros tenemos que
hacer
y este es ya que no está muy bien
enfocada por tal vez un falso sentido de
seguridad
el colegio este falso sentido de
seguridad que no quita del colegio y es
por eso que yo soy de la persona que
cree que el sistema educativo de nuestro
país no es correcto y si quiere que este
país de una forma más global porque
porque el colegio se focaliza solamente
en inteligencia matemática esto quiere
decir de que el sitio no se hace la mano
tiene buenas matemáticas
para que la mano de la mano tienes
matemáticas
estamos en la money
de la mano le consta las matemáticas
son cosas muy distintas partes la mano
la inteligencia en lo que con matemática
es una de 12 o de inteligencia solar en
una mesa entonces partiendo de ese punto
si alguien no les gusta las matemáticas
no es malo en matemáticas de bastante
probable que le vayan a pasar
y se los digo por conocimiento de causa
porque una vez yo sea el cuarto de media
fue junio de ese año y mis profesores
matemáticas textualmente me dijo de que
yo iba a fracasar en la ética
veredicto mis compañeros
estábamos haciendo los iniciados en mi
mente
en las habas yo estaba
no sumo con facilidad
bueno lo siento y la profesora que
estaba en el centro
esto ya no termina
todos los compañeros que se encuentran
listos y usted todavía
y me dijo
bastante y empezó a hablar
ustedes son simples copiadores
se sientan ahí en la carpeta copian pero
no razonan
yo le garantizo alumnos de que las
matemáticas están presente en todo en
toda carrera que ustedes elijan mañana
más tarde cuando las matemáticas
gracias
yo sé cómo termina
no
no no
aunque no
y le dijo que la pierna
y nunca más me llama la pesada
yo sé hoy esa persona
me llevo a marzo desde junio porque no
importa que el área le hiciera no
importa qué examen
mi nota más ante matemáticas es entonces
en sexto de primaria
y entonces cuando me voy a dar marzo y
sólo ocasional y entonces me tocó otra
profesora de la valdivia que pasa es que
mi hermana médico ya te fregaste se
empeora
entonces fui a vacacional iba todo en
esas tareas en febrero
y yo dijo acá está tu cuaderno
y trata de que
admitas a tu profesora que no te sale
dicho sea de paso nunca
entonces le dije no
me dijo que nueve de todos los días
temprano
hace la tarea hasta que puedes
no está mal
y le dije
vamos a ver
y dijo bueno a veces no sale
y otras veces no
cometan los errores que les dé la gana
llega tarde el trabajo y te van a votar
el que sabe matemática tiene la llave
del mundo
nunca
pero les puedo decir señores con
conocimiento de causa que si el que sabe
matemática tiene la llave del mundo los
trabajos que más ligados están con
el éxito tiene que ver con las
matemáticas ingeniería finanzas
arquitectura eso es cierto
pero el colegio no te dice que en el
mundo tiene más puertas y una que otra
ventana y usted tiene que aceptarlo
tienen que entenderlo porque lo que
ustedes hagan por su propia cuenta es lo
único que le va a dar calidad de vida
mañana más tarde cuando salgan del aula
cuando dejen el libro cuando se teje en
el cuaderno esto es una realidad y por
eso les digo de que existen verdades y
también existen mendia largados porque
si el que estudia triunfa cuñado pero yo
entendí de que la calle y el éxito es de
cualquiera
y ustedes también tienen que entenderlo
porque también existen elementos
herramientas que el colegio la
universidad el instituto no te las
brinda y tú tienes que tratar de
encontrarlos porque nosotros somos
mecánicos todos ustedes igual que todos
nosotros somos mecanismos hacemos lo
mismo de lunes a viernes nos apretamos a
la misma hora comemos de seguir aunque
lo que sea nosotros metropolitana carlos
taxi lo que sea vamos a colegios y todo
universidad con cierto tipo de haga que
lo que sea estamos hasta tomar break
almuerzo lo que sea volvemos al trabajo
al taxi el metropolitan sea
haces lo mismo de lunes a viernes y
entonces tienes que tener un escape y el
mundo te brinda es cambio son los
cambios sociales
fin
la juerga vicios
los videojuegos la moda pero existen
personas que estos escapes que son
insuficientes por eso toca zona guitarra
por eso que pintas por esas que escribes
por eso es que tienes que parar adelante
escape real hacia el mundo moderno
y empezamos a desarrollar la creatividad
de la mano quienes paper son creativos
son creativos
en la mano que son ex men
no existe nadie que no sea creativo no
existe y si alguien te hizo creer eso
está mal el ser humano crearle a con una
palabra con una oración crear construir
lo que sea pero si existen personas que
están que son más creativas que otras y
son en realidad por qué porque se
encuentran en un ambiente en el cual ser
instrumentada por actividad y estos
escapes
y estos elementos de la dieta que tienen
estos escapes son únicos porque vuelvo a
repetir no están en lo que nos presenta
el mundo en el que vivimos escuchar
aceptar ser un agente de propuestas ser
rápido
desarrollar tu naturaleza curiosa y
empezar a preguntarte más allá de lo que
nosotros vemos
por qué pasa esto porque pasando otros
elementos que te enseña tal vez es de
otros
la improvisación
y entonces la parte del cerebro que crea
se despierta
y empiezas a encontrar un gimnasio
creativo un escape y empiezas a abrazar
tus pasiones y empiezas a encontrar que
puedes apagar lo que te gusta con lo que
tienes ser y no te paras ni un solo día
de tu vida
porque no lo hacemos por miedo al miedo
así
el hermano tiene no tiene miedo
todo
no existe ninguna persona que no tenga
piedad
si no tuviera el miedo hace mucho tiempo
hubieran muerto
porque tiene atentos
miramos alrededor cortos también de la
foto el miedo y allí viene el problema
ahí viene la situación usted no tiene
que superar nada ustedes tienen que
acercar sus miedos ustedes tienen que
aceptar lo que son porque porque todos
nosotros por el miedo queremos cambiar y
cambiar nada no te acepte lo que aceptas
como eres identificas lo que no te gusta
el ibi del cambio pero nosotros no lo
vemos así
por tal expresión de grupo también la
sociedad tal vez el sistema no quiere
así
rechazamos otro elemento tan importante
que es el ridículo
hay mucha gente que vive muy bien de
película
y porque hablo del ridículo logró de
manera global
de manera más extensa porque porque a
nosotros nos importa muchísimo lo que
dice el amor lo que piensa en la otra
persona
igual tiene que pensar y no es una cosa
negativa es de que te acerques como eres
tú no hablas al paso por que naciste
hablando bajo tono miras al piso porque
naciste mirando el piso eso lo
aprendiste y de la misma forma que le
pediste le puedes dejar de aprender
y tenemos que entender que lo que
necesitamos es una decisión para
el iniciador del arte escuchar
aceptarnos como somos porque mi carrera
en la charla la aceptamos a todos a
todos somos raros encontrar gente muy
diferente a la gente quien se señala
cometer
y eso
que dice no puedes tratar mal nos puede
señalar cometer o especular de mí pero
lo que no puedes hacer es ignorar
aceite de comer es aceptar lo que haces
no evitamos hacer el ridículo pero
cuando tú aceptas lo que haces le quitas
el poder a la otra persona de juzgarte y
entonces eres libre
y yo quiero que entiendan son libres
puedes cambiar de parecer una y otra y
otra vez termina tú también la estudia
otra cosa es estudiar inglés
en inglés
él
pero porque no tienes sabías que existía
sabéis que saltamos pensamientos el
cambio empieza a desarrollar naturales
adquiridos a vuelvo a repetirte como les
dije hace un rato hay 12 tipos de
inteligencia la inteligencia lógico
matemática es una de dos que quiere
saber el resto cumple algo porque no te
lo voy a decir
pero te voy a decir que bailar eso que
inteligencia creen en dios su
inteligencia
es lo que he aprendido con alumnos
aprendido de gente que no tenía amigos
los rechazaban el bullying el mismo
sistema
perfecta que el miedo te consuma
de verdad
estos son los verdaderos cánceres del
nuevo milenio la ansiedad la depresión
el estrés cuando les digo de que todos
tenemos bien que tal es para ti hermano
el miedo destructivo
y entonces
de todos los demás
y vuelvo a repetir les estos elementos
tenemos que pararnos
si te gusta el cine el andar de cine de
autor me gusta leer perfecto abraza un
autor también
como yo
se puede decir que despierte a todo el
teatro
y entonces vas a empezar
entender la real dimensión del asunto
entonces terminado todo que no está bien
en la carrera que falta más cosas por
por lograr
y ustedes van a agarrar una computadora
a poner su nombre completo edad sus
redes sociales de poderoso todo
el colegio de estudiar y entonces toda
la carrera son cinco líneas
la pregunta es muy evidente porque el
miércoles te voy a elegir a ti
es que esas cinco líneas se vuelvan 10
12 20
si hablas inglés se la francés
si manejas tú manejas cambio escalante
este oratorio estás hecho intro y
entonces
las líneas de tu vida se amplían
y entonces quería tener por su mano para
decir a esta persona psiquiatra yo
quiero que se trae el mundo conmigo
una vez bueno alguna vez a dichos
talleres y una luna tuvo la osadía y el
hermoso atrevimiento de decir dichosa
gerente de recursos humanos de una
bucear vamos yo no veo eso
para nada
y unas notas
a ver lo que agarran los dos en los
currículos y veo cómo estás
y dije pero la gente entonces si tú
tienes los currículums
y los dos tienen 20 y uno de la
universidad lima y el otro de la mayor
aquí
tendría que analizar otras cosas
discúlpame
y creo que lo has hecho por otro motivo
porque te dije los hombres y
universidades
y creo que también estás equivocado
porque si esa persona no tiene estos
elementos que ustedes tienen que empezar
a desarrollar venga de donde venga
este mundo maravilloso de la guitarra es
maravillosa me encanta lo que hago es
una maravilla y eso también se lo desee
a ustedes porque ustedes ocupan un lugar
ustedes hacen una labor el trabajo que
sea de 100 personas 50 quiere tu trabajo
y de esas 50 30 lo pueden hacer mejor
que tú la pregunta es por qué lo haces
tú
no porque vaya ganando bardo y
necesariamente
pero de repente una persona puede pasar
espero que haya tenido este
haya recibido algo todo esto y les
agradezco la invitación
[Aplausos]
[Música]